arte france régis le sommier bonsoir
révises
comment tout simplement résoudre cette
crise en limant qui semble s'accélérer
de jour en jour en ce moment la crise et
les profondes depuis deux ans à la
descente aux enfers du liban il faut
imaginer un pays où tous les voyants
sont au rouge
l'économie la monnaie les tensions
communautaires qui sont extrêmement on
sait que c'est un pays qui est bâti sur
le communautarisme et sur le
confessionnalisme faut le rappeler c'est
un pays qui ressemble pas par exemple à
la syrie qui a connu énormément de
problèmes mais qu'il n'a pas cette
structure est aujourd'hui cette
structure héritée de la guerre civile
des années 80 eh bien elle pose problème
mais elle pose problème parce qu'elle
est remise en cause par un certain
nombre de personnes de ses propres
communautés et une énorme difficulté à
dépasser on l'a vu quand à la faveur de
cette malheureuse explosion du
centre-ville de beyrouth les français
ont essayé de devenir lalala emmanuel
macron s'est rendu au liban a essayé de
jouer et finalement d'une sorte de
bienveillance que la france toujours
comme on dispatche sur le liban est de 7
de ceux de cette image ça n'a pas
fonctionné on est revenu finalement on
vieilles habitudes de communautarisme
est aujourd'hui justement la faveur de
l' enquête sur cette explosion du centre
de beyrouth contestation notamment par
le hezbollah de la deûle enquête du juge
voilà à d'une certaine façon provoqué
des manifestations les manifestations il
y à une confrontation une vieille
confrontation finalement une
confrontation entre les chiites et une
milice comment les forces libanaises qui
font rappeler n'est quand même pas une
milice de deux personnes qui sont se
sont pas du tout délai des commandes et
des décommandé personnes il y a un passé
derrière il ya un passé derrière le
hezbollah il ya un passé derrière toutes
ces communautés est aujourd'hui
effectivement les tensions ce qu'on a
revu dans le quartier des yonnais
jeudi dernier est quand même regrettable
parce qu'on n'avait pas vu ça depuis la
guerre civile jusqu'à présent les
libanais avait hésité d'une certaine
façon même s'ils ont subi de
décontaminer par le jeu du sectarisme en
syrie il y a eu des combats il ya eu
d'aidé des tensions énormes pendant ces
deux trois dernières années mais les
libanais avaient toujours et ont
toujours à mon sens se souvenir de cette
guerre civile épouvantable
malheureusement ce qu'on a revu à taille
humaine et c'est quasiment sur la ligne
d anciens affrontements les les camps
les partisans des deux côtés se tirer
dessus parfois ou rpg donc scellé saine
gestion marqué l'esprit les esprits est
ce que régis ya un risque le liban
bascule
alors il ya effectivement un risque
parce que la différence entre les 10
dernières années quand y avait le voisin
syrien qui descendait en enfer les
libanais eux avait d'une certaine façon
conserver même s'il y avait des
difficultés une une santé économique qui
s'est progressivement qui a
progressivement décliné
aujourd'hui la crise financière est
énorme la communauté internationale
n'est pas venu au chevet du liban ça
c'est une bonne considérable même si joe
biden récemment accepté cueilli y ait
des approvisionnements notamment en
hydrocarbures égyptien et en électricité
jordanienne qui soit cheminée via la
syrie à des discussions pour mettre en
place ces structures pour pouvoir
vraiment épauler liban avance ans
personne n'a intérêt à ce que un nouveau
pays du moyen-orient
bascule dans la violence et bascule dans
la guerre civile le fait est que on a vu
aujourd'hui le discours d'hassan
nasrallah très clair
avouant pour la première fois que le
hezbollah avait cent mille combattants
il n'y a pas eu de réactions mais on est
dans cette confrontation n'est dans
cette montée des armes consent il ya une
odeur de poudre ont clairement qu ici ce
qui se répand et ce ne sont pas les
divers escarmouches qu'on a pu voir
entre des divers groupes qui existent
toujours au liban est un pays où des
armes ne sont jamais loin mais le le
évidemment souhaitons que le liban
n'arrive pas là qu'il arrive à retrouver
une cohérence et peut-être une aide de
cette communauté internationale parce
que de diminuer sa tête justement
financièrement comme elle
l'a fait à fonds perdus et c'était d'un
des principaux arguments comment
pourrait justement avancé par le
président ma kron de dire nous n'allons
pas venir louer de jean yves le drian
également nous n'allons pas venir
éternellement investir dans dans ce pays
si les choses ne sont pas réglées le
gouvernement le le liban s'est trouvé un
gouvernement il s'est trouvé un nouveau
premier ministre mais il n'est pas les
vielles habitudes sont là elles sont
claires le problème c'est que au niveau
du jeu américain au liban il ya quand
même des choses qui sont pas tout à fait
claires notamment
évidemment ce qui ce que laisse penser
une partie des médias américains c'est
que c'est lire en entier derrière ses
dires ont évidemment qu'il ya derrière
le hezbollah on le sait mais le
hezbollah n'est pas que le problème du
liban heures résumé ça à une agression l
iranienne comme on le voit parfois c'est
une annonce en ce cd problème libanais
la taxe sur le quartier de de taille ou
n'est elle a été en grande partie de la
faute des forces libanaises de samir
geagea donc on est voilà on est dans
l'affrontement sectaire et il n'y a pas
un camp et je précise que ses forces
sont soutenus par l'arabie saoudite donc
là encore une fois on retrouve les vieux
les vieux démons libanais avec ses
interventions 2 un de ces divers groupes
mais d'accuser simplement l'iran et de
dire 'voilà et le problème qu'on a dans
dans depuis depuis depuis très longtemps
on se rend compte sur la nature de
l'intervention ou la nature de de la
politique américaine au moyen-orient
c'est de dire quand on n'est pas
d'accord quand on le pays ne va pas dans
le sens dans lequel on va on veut qu il
aille eh bien on peut on pratiquer des
sanctions on pratique par le biais de
l'extraterritorialité de la loi
américaine est bien une imposition une
interdiction de la plupart des grandes
compagnies d'investir dans le pays donc
finalement qui paye les pots cassés à la
fin c'est le peuple c'est déjà le cas en
syrie c'est le cas en iran est-ce que ça
va être encore à nouveau le cas en liban
au liban est ce qu'on va affamer les
gens je rappelle qu'à une époque quand y
avait un problème avec un pays qui avait
qui avait feint un pays où connaissait
des famines on intervenait pour donner
de la nourriture aujourd'hui la
communauté internationale en particulier
l'occident intervient pour affamer des
populations donc la question elle est là
est-ce qu'on veut encore est-ce qu'on
veut pousser sur le bouton plus loin
évidemment les iraniens ne sont pas
totalement innocent dans cette histoire
il ya aussi une réforme est d'aider
comment des leviers appuyé de ce côté là
c'est une c'est un grave problème
aujourd'hui à prendre en cause d'eux
parlant de l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
sinon le liban va revenir à ce qu'il a
connu c'est à dire les démons de la
guerre civile les années 80 l'horreur
merci beaucoup régis le sommier d'avoir
été avec nous